c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
c'est que pour les là vincent sans plomb
27 10 10
clément dubois de l'est manu payet fait
nos prisons dirais qu'il est dans
questions pour un champion est comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane guillon [ __ ] je n'ai pas mais
il faut que je dise son nom sinon on ne
sera jamais battu sans quoi voilà je
vais te montrer que tu as vraiment je
suis ton pote et je vais faire pour toi
ce délire bonjour un sou tout
contentieux opposant direct dans une
émission qui se passe comment berne
parce qu'on n'ose à des débats qu'ils
font à l'élan béarnais n'aime pas mais
regarde ces questions moi je sais qui
c'est mais si vous trouvez chez vous
c'est impossible s'avère possible sortie
c'est malade que manière qui s'est pas
du tout mais non mais c'est introuvable
des puces a dirigé voulait que je
franchis pour les téléspectateurs
alors je vais refaire la même chose
quand mr x s'élève le château
les frangins wilhem que j'ai jamais
regardé il aime que je dise que ces
quatre mots la lui peut pas dire johnny
look annoncé johnny manon faso voice
taiwan les élèves le château vous avez
vos châteaux les élèves
vous allez à vos châteaux à ces jo même
à l'offre
[Musique]